Hello Everybody. My name is Markiplier!
and welcome back to diep.io. Now we're gonna
explore the other game mode that is available
that in my opinion is
incredibly fun and I'm gonna try to go a
completely different route than I've gone before
which is -- whoa
hey how's it going? So in this
one-- this is called dee-... uhh... *Markimoo noise*
This is called team deathmatch. I can't
even talk today, but I'm trying to
figure things out, but in this one, obviously
as is evident, in case it obviously
wasn't evident -- Oh my God --
there are two teams on the map.
And so these two teams are
fighting for control. Now the one thing
that I don't like about team deathmatch
is that all the bullets
are of the same color.
Are they? Wait, no. That doesn't seem right.
So in team deathmatch, I don't know why I
thought this, but I thought all of the bullets were of the same color.
But in this time, they are of
a different color, so you got your reds and
your bloos, an' they're all
fighten' against each other.
So in this one, this is actually a pretty decent one,
there's one guy on the blue team that seems to be
pretty high up on the leader boards, but
as far as we know,
it's fairly split even, which doesn't happen a lot
in team death match, so, my objective
is to get to number one on the leader board as usual,
like I usually do, but this time,
I'm gonna be doing it probably
as some sort of a sniper,
because I believe that I'll
be able to do better. Now the thing
about this one -- what makes this one interesting --
is that there's like, bases that
you can hide in, and so a lot of players
do, they just end up hiding in their base,
and they don't actually go out very much
and that's the coward's way out! Whoa, hey!
Hey big guy, how you doing over there?
So I'm gonna go sniper this time because I don't
usually do that. But sniper
is a little bit better because it allows
you to see more of the battlefield than what you
usually see in the other play styles,
which is very advantageous
when you're trying to-- whoop!
wooboboboboo -- and the bullets go
waaaay farther-- Oh my God.
Dude. Stop with your
triple cannons. Oh I almost
had ya buddy! What's wrong?
What's wrong? You wanna run away from the Marki-- oh...
you died. I dunno how he died.
Probably bumped up against an object and died.
What a loser!
Hey, it's Lie!
Oh geez, who's that over there?
Who's that over there? Someone crossed over enemy
lines and shouldn't be where you -- whoa geez.
Nooo. God, stop taking
up all the -- boooh that's not good.
Woo someone's on--
Woah geez. I forgot how far out I went.
I said, I'm just a litte baby Markifart,
I can't possibly handle all of the
death and destruction! Ha-BLUP!
(Weird attacking noises) *hableef-hableef-hablee-habloof*
Okay, I'm getting up there.
I'm level 22 now, so as-per-PER-PER
pretty soon I'll be able to do what I need to do.
I'm gonna get more reload speed because god damnit
I need more BULLETS!
I need more bullets pumped out of everywhere!
Because I gotta get some of these things killed or else
I'm never gonna get any goddamn points!
"Spin For Protection?!" I don't need your protection!
I go in RAAAAW!
Hello! Oh God. I don't know
what does that, it's like
the-- it-- for some-- there's a
type of, um,  there's a type
of tank that actually has, like,
little A.I.-controlled triangles
that'll go out and fuck up
everyone else's sheeit. And I don't
have those, and I don't know how to
get those... and also
in the middle-- oh, looks like the leader
got killed -- ehh
I didn't get it..(sped up "hebs")
heb-a-deh-eh-buh so snipers pretty basic
okay so I can be the assassin or the hunter
I don't know what the hunter is but I think the overseer is the thing that does the ships
I don't know what the hunter does though
i'm gonna try it I've never done it before
oh - whaat?
what is that? it's like a shotgun blast
well that's not helpful at all!
I guess actually this could definitely catch people off guard I bet
cause they wouldn't see it coming and it's kind of gotta spraay pattern
like a big one and a small one
HELLO
looks like red's kinda taken over the..whole place here
GEEZUMS so many reds
well I wanted a fair fight
I actually wanted a, uphill battle but it doesn't look like i'm gonna to get that
ooh hello
is this en-o-mies, en-o-mie/ o-mi's
let's get upgraded
let's get upgraaaayded
(fart noises because COMEDY)
Who's there? Who's there!
Huh? -- Oh shit.
That don't seem good.
Someone's over there.
I dont n-- I wasn't going for you little guy. I was going for the big guy wherever he is.
I am kinda close to enemy territory here.
I dont know if this is exactly where I want to be.
*Boink. Boink. Boink*
*deep sexual voce* I will kill.
You will kill?! The Markifart will kill more!
So blue team leader is over there somewhere. He's probably hiding out in the base because it seems to be pretty much stopped up.
Over here anyway
WOAH Wo-ho-ho. Woah!
Woah! That guy got destroyed!
Oh my god. I just saw my teammate get annihilated and I did nothing.
Ah well, what am I going to do.
What could I do?
*hyep* *habadooski* *habooski* *habrooski* *habruf* *habroof*
Ooh, I got a hit on that guy.
Woah geez
Woah garsh.
I shouldn't be this far deep in enemy territory.
*huh*
I gotta get back to the middle because that's where I'll get most my points.
because this is just competition
Man it's gonna be a long climb to the top
ooh geez.
But I- I can see the advantage of this thing already because
my bullet speed is so high that it's easy for me to sneak up on people and
and nab them before they're able to get away
and the damage is ridiculous so
all good features
Ah! But I'm not even on the leaderboard yet!
I'm an embarrassment to everybody that ever played this game
I can do better!
I can always do better! I know I can do better.
I've done better before.
I've dominated the leaderboards.
Arguably, something other than this...
I've kind of handicapped myself as far as getting points goes.
Unless I kill. Other. People.
Which I think is my only want in life
so I shall do exactly that
And if I can't succeed in that then I'm not worthy of even being here.
I'm not worthy of being -alive-.
Ah! Woah geez.
Woah geez. x2
Ooh garsh.
Oooh garsh. x2
Someone-- someone's doing a thing.
Did I kill him? All the sudden the bullets stopped!
Ooh hey. *boink* Hahahaha
Okay so now that's good. There's like an announcement when you actually kill somebody.
which is awfully handy
I like that
Thank you for the shield Axel.
You definitely helping me out here.
I don't think you can shoot anything into their spawn
Ooh. Kill dat guy. I killed him dead.
Woah my god.
Thanks for the support everybody -- Oh Axel .
Axel was in trouble there.
Holy shit. Those things HURT
Oh my god those things hurt.
AAH Stop! Im busy!
Ooh I killed somebody a-a-accidentally
But I killed somebody big and I don't even know how.
Woah geez I got points out of that one.
WOOH
I got up to level 45 already. I'm on the leaderboard baby!
I don't know who I killed. L-O-L
I guess he must have been big.
Woah-- LMFAO huh?
LMFA Dead
I think those must be like, these must be like automated things that just fire out of the blue base
To try to
Gaha, hone in on the red base maybe, I have no idea
Hard to say
Ro-Ho!
*In a siren manner* Woah! Woah! Woah! Woah!
Spraying!
Someone's spraying
Oh, someone's spraying way too much
Oh geez!
I can't handle spray of this magnitude
I will admit, Hunter's not my favourite thing
Its-It doesn't seem to be as powerful as something could be
I mean its pretty good if I keep shooting in a certain direction
Buuut
*Indecipherable gargling*
Just based random chance I dunno if I'm gonna get the kills that I wanna get
Oh, also!
People have mentioned that I could just hold down the button and---
Oh! I killed Carson!
Yeah!!! Uh...Sorry!
Killed MM---MG---E---
*Baby noises*
Uop!
Killed MGSavagePro
I'm killin' up a storm of weaklings
*Chuckles*
Doesn't matter if they can't pull up a fight
Alright
Let's see if Axel's gonna give me the support I need
Wupp! Killed ASDF again! That guy keeps running into death
Over and over again
Go Axel! Go!
Go Axel! Go! x2
I got your back! From waaaaaay over here!
Uh-oh!
Axel got killed!
Nevermind Axel!
I don't got your back!
I got LOL again!
Uh!!!!
I killed tt!
I dunno who tt was
but probably an easy target.
LMFAO, you wanna come back here? I wanna play
I wanna play~
I wanna plaaaaaay~
Oh I killed Kikuuwugwu *unintelligible noise*
I killed an unnamed tank
I feel bad
kind of - maybe - a little bit
not really
YES! COMBINE OUR FORCES!
This is how we do it!
Hopefully
I don't know if it's going to work
But this is how some people do it
OHH KILLED AN UNNAMED TANK!
I'm on the leaderboard baby!
Yeah-ha-ha!
And with that my power grows
My power grows infinitely.
Unlimited-idly
See this is what I like about the game mode because you can push with your team mates
Or you can try to go on your own if you're like a sniper class like me.
but ya- but for the most part like i-- like its-- it's really like a rallying cry when you're just
all together as one
and able to just push the enemy back
and right now it's kind of one-sided
when I started the game it was-- it was ya know-- fairly even
but now it's gotten a little bit embarrasing
like before-- the enemy had one of the biggest--
players on the board and probably when he died one of our guys got really big so
that's unfo-- woahh shit.
Oh god. That was probably gonna be death if I would've gone even a little bit for it.
I would've been caught by all three.
Which is not good!
I want it!  I waaant it! I waaaaant it!
I WANT IT! Ah shit.
It's just more satisfying to click randomly.
to click spasticly~~
forever and ever
Okay I'm number 7 on the leaderboard. 6 on my team
LMFAO! Looks like you died at some point-- I almost had you
Hmm
I killed an unnamed tank though
I keep feeling bad about that I--
I feel like these unnamed tanks are just new guys that are just starting out
and they have nothing left
I could kill you! I could kill you~~
I just choose not to
Actually I definitely choose to
We're just going to see where you pop up, if you go north or south
Uh oh.
Ah, looks like I may have some controversy up here.
Does anybody wanna fight the Markifart!
Im number FIVE~~ BABY!
numba five~~
Some uh-- *pfbt* Uh some unfortunate son of a bitch is gonna come-- uh well, that guy
Some uh other unfortunate son of a bitch is gonna come across one of my bullets
and then die in a horrible blazing fiery death of death-- ness!
Who's down here? MG Cody!
MG Cody?! DONEZO!
Who else is down here-- BOBB!?
I'm gonna get you bob!
MG cool--Dead.
The hunter steals all kills.
The hunter claims all credit.
Where you going Ricardo?
WOAH-- That's where you're going, away from him.
Oh shit.
Get that guy-- wooh clear that guy
Clear that-- I said clear THAT GUY. Jeezums.
Ughh
Oh shi-- OH FUCK ME! WHAT THE FUCK!
OH COME ON!
OH FUCK OFF!
What even was that?!
What the fuck just happened?!
Oh goddammit!
What the fuck happened?
WHAT?~~
Oh goddammit. Somehow I just googled *dee-di-te-dee-dee-dee* (ddddd)
HOW DID I DO THAT?!
WHAT THE FUCK WAS THAT?!
Goddammit I was in the middle of a GOD DAMN GAME
HOW THE FUCK DID THAT HAPPEN?
How did I google Dee-di-dee-dee
I killed him so long ago!
What the fuck was that?!
(Mark singing) *woo-ta-do-ta-doo-do-doo-la-do-doot-doodle-doot-- doot*
*do-do-ta-doot-toot-doot-ta-doodlelootta- doot do-do-do*
*Do-da-doot-doot-doodle-do-da-doot-doot-deww*
*da doot-da doo*-- Oh fuck. All right, whatever.
Goddammit. UGH I'm not gonna be I-- de-- tuh-- I-- I can't do it back again. Okay!
So I guess that's the premature end~~ of this episode of Diep.io. Even though I've been playing for like 30 minutes... BUT STILL!
That's not fair!
what the fuck...
Anyway, alright, but that's team deathmatch mode.
Team deathmatch is fun in my opinion, but there's another game mode called domination
that iI've never played before, so I have no idea if it's good or not
but I hear it'd the only one that has a "win condition"
So team death match might be team-vs-team, but there's no way to win for your team
but in domination, SUPPOSEDLY, there is, so we will explore that in the next episode of Diep.io
Thank you everybody so much for watching, and as always, I will see YOU in the next video
BUH-BYE!~~
Wuh? you wanna come at me bro? You wanna come after triple-penis-enis?
Ah fuck you bruh, Fuck you bruh!
Ooooh you want a hug? You wanna hug lady?
All right, too bad, all I have is death.
meep